my coach is here to pull me from this
show cuz we're just halfway through cuz
steve married she's gonna pull a Bill
O'Brien here on the show how are you
Steve
good morning rich are we doing today
what's the quickest you ever pulled a
starting quarterback into a season
starting quarterback no further I mean
cuz Bill O'Brien started two years in a
row now where he's changed his guy
halfway through the first game geez well
the first even rich that I ever coached
I didn't have to pull Steve Young he got
a concussion from Warren Sapp in the
second quarter boom out and I'm going oh
geez I came all the way here to San
Francisco to see this and then Jerry
Rice got heard about three plays later
but I don't remember pulling a starting
quarterback I don't I don't want to say
ever but never in the first half so what
is what is go what goes through Bill
O'Brien's mind where where he can or
let's put it this way doesn't that
resonate with in a locker room if some
guy goes all summer long this is our guy
we're going in a battle with this guy
and all it takes is 30 minutes of
adversity and it's it's we're gonna try
something else well here's the deal you
changed quarterbacks for several reasons
sometimes it's like alright that's the
last straw he's out I'm moving on that
doesn't seem to be the case with them
the others the other reason would be
okay this guy this guy's not not doing
it today it's not his day I need a spark
I need something to happen good to get
the fans back in the game see if we can
change the course here a little bit and
I think that's what he did now Tom
Savage is not like he's been around for
12 years and then starting in this
league he's he's a young guy too and so
you saw DeAndre Hopkins right yeah he
said I want savage and and and DeSean
Watson's from his school so I heard that
yeah so so right then and there you say
well first of all this team is being
good DeAndre is being good about being a
good teammate and supporting whoever's
there alright but I think it was a good
decision to make a change and see if
they can get something going because
that was a rich let's face it that was a
different game okay that was a different
deal down there with Houston with
hurricane Harvey with their lack of
practice cancelling the preseason game
in this the emotion and it was it was on
lievable and we all thought that that
would just carry over into a whap sided
victory well it didn't and so you know
he just he just said let's see if we can
change our spark right here and maybe
deshaun Watson can can pull off a minor
miracle and get us started here but now
he's got a decision to make you know
because Dashon did some good things he
wasn't great either but he ran a couple
times for some years he he did complete
some POW he did Drive in the end zone
one time so to me interesting the middle
right now well I mean he said that to
the media but he's made his decision now
right I mean you can't be non-committal
on such a short week on Monday right
yeah you know I don't know if he's made
a decision you know I think he's got to
just kind of say oh how ready is DeSean
watch and how much practice time and
that's what we you and I don't know we
haven't been there watching practices is
he ready to go win a game in a short
week it's if they're a bye week and you
say alright I'm making a change he's
going to get two weeks of practice snaps
and that might be better for him to play
well but there's only a couple days of
shorts practice that's all you get you
kid a little practice in shorts and so
he's got to decide would would be
embarrassed to Sean Watson by not
practicing enough against this other
defense or do we go with the guy who's
got a little bit more experience under
his belt what would you do you know I I
don't know I don't know the kids rich I
mean I don't want to dodge the question
but I don't know the kids well enough
from practice and all that to say I
disguise our future I like to Shawn
Watson he was one of our Under Armour
all-americans okay I gotta have a little
bias but he did show me enough he's an
exciting guy we watched him against
Alabama you know he's he's got he seems
to have a little bit more upside to me
Steve Mariucci my compadre from NFL
gameday morning and he will be with me
and the gang on Thursday night to kick
off week two between the Texans and the
Bengals on NFL Network only by the way
so what what gives with Seattle's
offense look and the Giants offense I
understand that Green Bay and Dallas
played stout defensive games but just
seeing what you saw from these offenses
what what concerns you Steve
yeah you know rich I did what I took
from this this first weekend was we this
is her made worse that's why we play the
games I saw some teams that we thought
were going to beat bad teams let's just
call it like it is I thought there was
going to be some bad teams the Browns
the Jags the Bears you know we thought
that they're really developing and
training transition got a long way to go
they all played well better than
expected and then we saw some really
good teams really good teams the
Patriots right Seattle the Giants who
else
Pittsburgh didn't play all that well and
and and you say well geez they what
happened you know we thought they'd be
awesome and they weren't and so
Seattle's one of them Seattle's a heck
of a team now you've been to Lambeau
Field
that's a tough out for anybody to go in
there and I be quite honest with you the
Green Bay Packer defense was better than
I thought it was going to be and an
Aaron Rodgers didn't have a good game
either that was a kind of a defensive
struggle
Xero's at halftime which and those are
the two winningest organizations in the
National Football League are in the
National Football Conference since
Russell's been in there but yeah
Seattle really had a really struggle to
to move the ball Russell Wilson was
their leading rusher again why do they
let see why do they always have problems
on that off on that side of the ball
it's just an Eddie Lacy didn't do a darn
thing
get five carries for three yards against
the Packers you thought he'd be like
motivated to have a stellar game nothing
and so you know and then Rawls was out
right hmm I think they missed him
Carson Katz gonna wind up with the job
so if I had asked you which offense you
think has the opportunity to rebound
faster Giants or Seattle but what's your
answer Steve probably Seattle I'm gosh
well you know the Giants are missing
Odell Beckham that's a huge part of it
too but where they struggle a little bit
is where their offensive line I don't
know if it's good enough and that you
know that comes along slowly it's not
like you just beam me up another lineman
that's the attles problem to that the
fan kid got hurt their left tackle
remember and the preseason blew his knee
out yes
Tom clear ball has always been like
patching it up with that offensive line
I think we're learning I think we're
learning you know we all play fantasy
football right I don't both fantasy
football well and you learn about the
skilled players in this league right the
guys have scored touchdowns but but the
general fan doesn't doesn't really watch
the offensive linemen well we're finding
out you better darn well have a good
offensive line if you want to get things
done and Dallas is proving that every
year Dallas is drafted very well with
that offensive line well the Giants
don't have a very good offensive line
Seattle's got a nope just an okay
offensive line and yet boy starts there
do you want the quarterback to be any
good he better protective his butt Steve
Mariucci couple more minutes with him
Steve the the coaching decision that I
saw number one that made me scratch my
head and it's not because it didn't work
out was Mike Mularkey starting the
season off with an onside kick I mean I
couldn't look it I know it didn't work
out and it had it worked out we might be
talking about all there's malarkey
rolling the dice isn't he a genius but
what are you a defensive unit that that
wants to show it its championship
quality with Dick LeBeau you walk up to
Dick LeBeau before the game and the
defense and say we're going on side I
mean doesn't that leave a mark Bowe had
his 80th birthday I know that right the
team a little birthday party for me 80th
I hope I lived that long and he's the
defensive coordinator and so remember
Jack Del Rio did that last year in the
first game he went for - he said heck
with it well that's a different story is
that different I mean it's not the first
play of the game but it's like this
we're making a statement here this that
this team is going to just you know
we're confident if it works fine if it
doesn't find I'm confident that our
defense will hold up it's kind of like
one of those things that a little bit of
arrogant they say I'm just doing it and
then see what happens
Sean Payton didn't did it in the
Superbowl but I didn't work out
Tennessee's probably going to win that
division no well I mean cuz the culture
looked absolutely dreadful I mean I boy
I mean I don't even know what Chuck
Pagano does there I wouldn't put Andrew
Luck behind that line even if he has to
be a hundred percent I wouldn't do no I
I feel bad for Chuck and he's a heck of
a coach but that
that roster I'm looking at the roster
you know how many blue chip players do
they have I'm how many how many kind of
Pro Bowl kind of guys do they have on
that team the Rams just had their way
with them in the Rams my hat's off to
Shaun they I mean Jesus that the Rams
look like a real team yeah they did they
didn't even have ironed Aaron Donnell
out there and had a defensive hootenanny
against the the Colts before he let
Steve go ask him the poll question Chris
Brockman go for it
all right mooch what's the biggest
surprise from football week one Rams
highest scoring team in the league Jags
in first place Giants and Seahawks
combined for zero touchdowns Bengals
shutout at home or Oklahoma beats Ohio
State in college Baker Mayfield going to
the O in the middle and sticking that
flag in there and then it was in the
turf was that crazy what a great weekend
ojas so good to be back with all this
stuff biggest surprise biggest surprise
yeah maybe Seattle and the Giants not
scoring touchdowns
that's unbelievable yeah when you see
Mayfield you see a pro quarterback Steve
pardon me
when you see Mayfield do you see a
professional National Football League
successful quarterback when you say and
yes and yes this kid's got you know you
know he's first of all he's bigger than
I thought he was okay I thought he was
like a next Flutie a little bit bigger
you know but he's 6 1 to 20 and he's got
some spunk now he's got some grit and I
yeah he's gonna play in the National
Football League all right Steve you take
care of yourself I'll see you all right
we're moving on to Cincinnati Steve on
to Cincinnati you are gonna go right
you're going you'll be there I'm going
today I'm so fired up I can't wait
that's not true
that's so false that is such a that's
hashtag all right Steve I hope you
enjoyed watching my two lone wolves on
gameday morning be correct I hate when
that happens
we always hear about it I heard about it
I'm gonna text the guys you do it em I
heard about it on Monday already that's
right you'll hear about it the Tuesday
Wednesday and Thursday
Thanks and Saturday in the meeting take
care of mooch if I hear the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon
Eastern on radio stations across the
country
and audience if you liked some of that
get some more of that on the Rich Eisen
show app follow all the information you
see right here on the Rich Eisen show